pour le spray nasal antico vite 19
développé par une équipe de chercheurs
tourangeau entre dans une nouvelle phase
une start up vient d'être créé pour
soulever des fonds et faciliter sa
commercialisation elle pourrait
intervenir d'ici deux ans les dernières
études le confirment ce vaccin parvient
à bloquer la transmission du virus
romain delville c'est donc ici à mam que
vient de s'installer l'eau valtech pour
loire valley technologies la start up
pour développer et financer le vaccin
par voie nasale contre lakovic 19 après
les subventions publiques il reste un
peu plus de 3 millions d'euros à trouver
pour produire des lots cliniques du
vaccin en vue de faire des essais la
mission en fait que j'ai la preuve pour
cette année c'est en dès le premier
trimestre d'aller rencontrer des
investisseurs donc on est en train
justement là actuellement de regarder
les listes des investisseurs que nous
allons contacter nous sommes pour ce
faire
supporter par la vue pays ici les
espoirs sont grands de voir le vaccin
nasale supplanter le vaccin
intramusculaire car les résultats sont
probants en créant une réponse
immunitaire des fosses nasales le vaccin
tourangeau fermerait la porte d'entrée
du virus en faisant agir d'autres
protéines que la spike celle qui a une
fâcheuse tendance à muter de betao
micron en passant par le variant delta
on a également inclus d'autres protéines
et l'intérêt de ces autres protéines
c'est qu'elle ne mute jamais quelles que
soient les mutants donc par exemple si
on regarde ces protéines dans la souche
quran dans la souche delta ou dans la
souche mikron elle est la même donc du
fait d'avoir incorporé ces protéines qui
ne mute pas ce seront des protéines qui
sont toujours reconnus via le système de
vaccination est donc ils vont faire que
notre vaccin va pouvoir être un vaccin
polyvalent et répondre quel que soit le
type de variants si le plan se déroule
sans accroc les essais cliniques
commenceront à la fin de l'année et la
commercialisation pourrait intervenir
fin 2023 début 2024